fans are adding Tom Hanks's recent
coronavirus diagnosis to the never
ending list of things the Simpsons has
freakishly predicted in their 30-plus
years on the air The Simpsons has become
something of a prophetic franchise with
several series plot points that became
to various degrees a reality among the
series weirdest and wildest predictions
were the winners of several Super Bowls
the Siegfried and Roy Tiger attack and
most recently Donald Trump's
presidential election did you say of
tough dry wind your daughter loves you
tough try Washington okay okay the both
great team because of The Simpsons track
record for calling the future sometimes
decades before it happens bands are now
freaking out about what they see as an
uncanny link between Tom Hanks's cameo
in 2007's The Simpsons Movie
and his crow no virus quarantine after
he and his wife Rita Wilson tested
positive for the virus at one point in
the film the castaways star appears in
an advertisement for a new Grand Canyon
being built in Springfield during the
end credits of the movie Hanks voicing
himself has a little something extra to
say this is Tom Hanks saying if you see
me in person please leave me be
many are taking this gag is a prediction
of Hank Cisco vid 19 diagnosis while
there have certainly been a few shocking
parallels between the Simpsons plot
lines and real-life events the
connection between Hanks is quarantine
and the PSA style cameo is pretty thin
first of all Hanks isn't ill in the
Simpsons Movie he's simply using his
credibility to help out the government
and advertise the new Grand Canyon that
will replace Springfield it's easy to
see how the parallels between the movies
quarantine situation and Hanks's
predicament might have some crossover
but it's a weak link at best not only
does the dialogue in question sound like
something just about every famous person
says about going out in public but the
circumstances of the quarantine are also
drastically different the cameo in Hanks
his current status actually mirrors some
of the Simpsons other softer predictions
like the three-eyed fish part found near
a Springfield power plant during a 1990
episode mirroring three-eyed fish that
was discovered in a reservoir in
Argentina
near a nuclear power plant nearly a
decade later there are similarities
between what happens in the Simpsons
movie and what's going on in real life
but anyone claiming that the film
predicted Hanks getting the chronal
virus is committing a huge leap in logic
ha ha trapped forever
oh come true over the years fans and
even some conspiracy theorists have
helped build the myth that the Simpsons
can predict the future but the show's
writers have long made clear that some
of the weird are messed up things in the
Simpsons aren't mystical back in 2010
bill Oakley an executive producer on the
show at the time told the New York
Observer that the series is 9/11
connection in the city of New York
versus Homer Simpson episode is a
completely bizarre and strange thing but
also acknowledged that the episode was
full of World Trade Center material that
strange so-called prediction was noticed
by fans who saw Lisa Simpson holding a
guidebook on New York City
featuring the price of $9 next to a
picture of the Twin Towers Simpsons
writer Al Jean told BBC Radio 1 news
beats in 2019 that the 9/11 prediction
was totally coincidental and chalked up
things like the foreshadowing of Trump's
election to just having a smart bunch of
writers who read the news and tune into
current events in the case of Trump it
was all about remembering he had
publicly expressed interest and running
for president before as Jean explained
if you make enough predictions then 10%
will turn out to be right writer
Stephanie Gillis added we are sort of
futurologists in that we write 10 months
ahead so we're trying to guess what is
going to happen in a property pact with
references to art literature pop culture
politics and science and one that's
written by some of the smartest people
on Hollywood maybe the only genuinely
predictable thing here is that people
will always read way too much into what
The Simpsons has done in the past my
predictions you couldn't predict 6
o'clock at 5:30
[Music]